- This is one for
the whole family.
We see all these
beautiful bodies or faces,
and we hear R.
Kelly song playing.
No actually, fuck R.
Kelly, cause he peed
on my grandma one time.
He came to our church
and did a speech,
and he just-- the
whole front row.
Alright, Brandy. We use Brandy.
Brandy is way better.
Like sweet Brandy, back when
she first got her titties,
like around when
Moesha was coming out.
Okay, so we hear
the Brandy song.
People are like hooping,
dancing, performing,
like a little talent show.
And then we hear
Brandy comes out.
Now, we gotta do wide shot
of Brandy because Brandy's
eyes is where her ears is at.
She might be the hammerhead
shark of the R&B world.
Brandy's like, "At Emerson
Funeral Home, we want you to
die looking sexy as hell,
cause you might
be going to hell".
Kyron, Emerson Funeral
Home, die sexy.